So there are more developments in the Democratic
primary just the week before the first democratic
debates with your next Wednesday and Thursday.
There are now two Saint Paul's
in which Elizabeth Warren has actually pulled
ahead of Bernie Sanders into second place.
And this is absolutely fascinating in terms
of just the dynamics of the primary going
into the debate.
It's fascinating in terms of the sort of progressive
front runner status that Bernie Sanders has
had and in the average still continues to
have with the exception of these two poles.
And that's what I want to be clear about.
In an average of recent polls, Bernie Sanders
is still solidly in second place ahead of
uh, Elizabeth Warren by an average of about
three percentage points, but it is getting
very close.
Okay, so on this chart, Joe Biden is the top
green line and I'll describe to you the numbers.
So if you're listening and not watching, don't
worry.
Bernie Sanders is the Light Blue Line and
Elizabeth Warren is the brown line in third
place.
Now to quickly reset, you'll notice Joe Biden's
spiked to 42 when he announced he was running
for president.
He trailed off more and more.
Uh, has continued to decline now down to an
average of 32, uh, almost down to where he
was preannouncement and down about 10 points
from his high.
Early on it was Bernie Sanders who was gaining
from Joe Biden's declines and you'll see that
for a period of time Bernie was climbing basically
in parallel with Joe Biden's decline, about
80% of Joe Biden's decline early on went to
Bernie Sanders.
And as I told you at the start of this week,
Bernie's climbs have slowed.
And in fact, Bernie Sanders has actually started
to trail off a little bit in recent polls
from closer to 18 down to 15 recently.
And it is Elizabeth Warren who still slow
and steady, has picked up another point or
so.
And is it solidly at 12%.
More interesting though is that there are
two recent polls that actually straight up
have Elizabeth Warren ahead of Bernie Sanders.
Now we're putting this up on the screen now
for our video audience.
In a recent Monmouth poll released yesterday,
Elizabeth Warren is now up 15 to 14 over Bernie
Sanders.
Now, yes, it's within the margin of error
and an economist poll released just a few
days ago.
Elizabeth Warren is up 16 to 12 over Bernie
Sanders starting to get to the edges of the
margin of error.
So these are just two poles.
Bernie Sanders is still ahead of Elizabeth
Warren in most polls, the margin of error
matters, but this is a change from two months
ago.
If you go to two months ago, Bernie was averaging
22 and Elizabeth Warren was at five or six
Bernie quadrupling Elizabeth Warren two months
ago and now they are almost effectively tied
within the margin of error with Elizabeth
Warren in the lead in a couple of Poles.
So I liked Bernie Sanders.
I Like Elizabeth Warren.
What I like about this is the way that Elizabeth
Warren is doing this, she has come from behind
with a policy and substance campaign, which
I love.
No Ad Hominems, no flash, no even massive
media coverage, really nothing other than
just diving deep on policy, explaining to
people why her ideas are as far as she's concerned,
the solutions to the problems that we're facing
as a country.
And I think that this makes the debates that
are starting next week even more interesting.
You might remember that because of there are
I guess 20 Democratic candidates who have
qualified for the first debate on the basis
of either 65,000 donors from at least 20 different
states, I believe it is, uh, some minimum
number from each state or at least 1% in three
polls.
Uh, there are 28 candidates in total who have
qualified on the basis of one or the other
of those standards.
Many would not have qualified if they were
both requirements, but because it is one or
the other, there are 20 candidates participating
in the debates that start next week.
That is so many that they have split the debate
into two parts night, a night be Wednesday
and Thursday.
Interestingly, Elizabeth Warren is on night
a separated from all of the other front runners.
She's separated from Biden who's on night
be, she's separate from Bernie.
She's separate from Buddha judge and Harris.
Uh, that is potentially a great opportunity
for Elizabeth Warren to be the lone front
runner on what is officially the first night
of debate in the Democratic primary.
Uh, it also could be maybe something that
will hurt Elizabeth Warren in the sense that
she will not even be on the same stage as
all of the other front runners.
And maybe we'll be sort of incorrectly be
seen as being at the kids' table, so to speak,
even though that is not how it is being divided
up in this particular debate.
So we'll see.
But what I will be addressing on the Friday
show tomorrow, uh, relates to whether the
fact that both Warren and Bernie are, uh,
the progressive candidates, so to speak, and
are in second and third place respectively,
is that in some way going to weaken the progressive
movement against the centrist candidate, the
establishment candidate, Joe Biden.
Uh, we'll talk about that tomorrow.
And I want to hear from you.
Do you think that Elizabeth Warren being separated
from the, and when I say being separated,
not proactively as far as we know by the DNC,
this is how the draw happened to come out.
If we take their word for it, uh, which many
of us don't, but many, many of us do at least
to some degree.
Will this hurt her or will this help her?
I want to hear from you
about
this issue.